♪ ♪
>> Sean: BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS
TODAY WITH THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
AMASSING A NUMBER SOUTHERN
BORDER.
DO YOU OFFICIALS HAVE NOW
ARRESTED 34 MIGRANTS ON CHARGES
LIKE DRUG POSSESSION, PUBLIC
INTOXICATION, RESISTING THE
POLICE.
MEANWHILE, AN ACTIVIST JUDGE IN
SAN FRANCISCO TEMPORARILY
BLOCKING THE ADMINISTRATION
POLICY OF DENYING ASYLUM TO
MIGRANTS WHO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR, LINDSEY
GRAHAM WITH A REACTION.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY
ARE SCARING PEOPLE BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
IT'S REAL.
HALF THE PEOPLE IN TIJUANA SAY
THAT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN INVADED.
BUT IT NOW HERE IT I WANT TO GET
YOUR REACTION.
HOW DO WE HANDLE THIS?
>> NUMBER ONE, IF IT WEREN'T FOR
A FOX NEWS YOU WOULD KNOW THAT
PEOPLE IN TIJUANA HAVE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH US.
THE PEOPLE THERE ARE PUSHING
BACK HARD.
UNDER OUR LAW, IF WE COME HERE
ILLEGALLY YOU CAN STILL SEEK
ASYLUM AND ONCE YOU MAKE AN
ASYLUM APPLICATION, IT TAKES
MONTHS FOR IT TO GET THROUGH.
WE WIND UP RELEASING YOU INTO
THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS NUTS.
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION EARLY IN THE NEXT
CONGRESS TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
YOU COME HERE ILLEGALLY YOU CAN
NEVER APPLY FOR ASYLUM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RIGHT TO
CHANGE HIS POLICY AND WE WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: IT RIGHT.
I HAVE YOUR STATEMENT ON
SAUDI ARABIA.
I DON'T THINK THERE HAS BEEN
ANYONE IN THE MEDIA MORE
CRITICAL MORE REGULARLY FOR MORE
YEARS AND THEN SAUDI ARABIA.
HOW THEY TREAT WOMEN, CHRISTIANS
AND, GAYS AND LESBIANS.
WITH THAT SAID, I THINK M.B.S.
PROBABLY DID KNOW AND ORDER THE
KILLING OF JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, WORLD WAR II
WE HAD TO ALIGN WITH A MASS
MURDER BY THE NAME OF JOSEPH
STALIN TO DEFEAT HITLER.
WE DIDN'T LIKE THAT ALL LIENS,
EITHER.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE A HISTORIC
MOMENT WHERE U.S., ISRAEL,
EGYPT, JORDAN, THE EMIRATES, THE
SAUDIS ARE NOW PERFECTLY ALIGNED
AGAINST IRANIAN HEGEMONY AND THE
THREATS OF THEM GETTING A
NUCLEAR WEAPON WITH THEIR
RADICAL IDEOLOGY OF WANTING TO
DESTROY THE WORLD AND AMERICA
AND ISRAEL.
I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT
SANCTIONS, I BELIEVE THERE
SHOULD BE A PUNISHMENT, BUT I
ALSO AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
THERE SHOULD NOT BE ENDING THE
RELATIONSHIP.
>> EVERYTHING YOU SAID IS TRUE
ABOUT THE STRATEGIC NATURE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP, BUT HERE'S
WHAT I BELIEVE.
SAUDI ARABIA NEEDS AS MORE THAN
WE NEED THEM.
IT'S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK AN ALLY
NOT TO BUTCHER A GUY IN A
CONSULATE.
THIS IS NOT WORLD WAR II SO I AM
NOT GOING TO LOOK AWAY AT WHAT
M.B.S. DID.
I THINK HE DID IT, --
>> Sean: I DO, TOO.
ISN'T THERE A DANGER WE COULD
PUSH HIM INTO THE ARMS, WE DROVE
HIM INTO THE ARMS OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN, IRAN, SYRIA, AND
CHINA?
>> I WILL BE HONEST WITH YOU,
SEAN.
THERE IS NO WAY NO WAY
SAUDI ARABIA IS EVER GOING TO
ALIGN WITH OUR OWN, THEY MORTAL
ENEMIES.
>> Sean: I GOT IT.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS, I CARE
ABOUT THE STRATEGIC
RELATIONSHIP.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT ISRAEL
COMPLETELY BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
TURN MY BACK ON THIS GUY.
WE'VE GOT AT HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL THE PEOPLE
IN THE MID EAST THERE IS A NEW
SHERIFF IN TOWN.
IF YOU DISRESPECT US THEN YOU
TRAMPLE OVER CIVILIZED NORMS
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY A PRICE.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP M.B.S., THAT
IS YOUR DECISION TO MAKE,
SAUDI ARABIA.
AS LONG AS YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION, YOU HAVE A HARD TIME
WITH ME.
IF YOU WANT TO REPLACE HIM WITH
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT CRAZY, THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD MOVE.
>> Sean: YEAH, I AGREE WITH
YOU.
>> IT'S NOT COMPLICATED TO ME.
I LIKE SAUDI ARABIA, BUT THIS
GUY IS CRAZY AND NEEDS TO GO.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY REALLY
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOMENT IN
HISTORY, THIS STRATEGIC ALLIANCE
WOULD ACTUALLY BE --
>> TOTALLY, 100%.
>> Sean: THE MOMENT IN MY
MIND, BRING PEACE IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IRANIANS ARE FAR TOO DANGEROUS.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THAT MOMENT TO
COME WHEN THEY HAVE NUKES.
LET ME ASK YOU --
>> RADICAL ISLAM WITH A NUCLEAR
WEAPON IS REALLY DANGEROUS.
>> Sean: YEAH.
THAT'S A BAD SCENARIO.
AG, WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE?
>> I DON'T REALLY...
MR. BARR IS GOOD, THERE ARE A
LOT OF GOOD CHOICES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOMEBODY IN
PLACE NEXT YEAR WHO CAN GUIDE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IN A NEW
DIRECTION.
I THINK JEFF SESSIONS HAD TO GO.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT TO
REPLACE HIM.
I LIKE MR. WHITAKER FINE BUT I
DON'T THINK HE'S THE PERMANENT
SOLUTION.
I PROMISE YOUR VIEWERS, IF I AM
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WE WILL FIND OUT
ABOUT THE FBI THE WAY THEY GOT A
FISA WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAG
PAGE.
100%.
IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE OTHER
FOOT, THEY WOULD BE CRUCIFYING
US RIGHT NOW IF THIS WAS A
WARRANT ISSUED AGAINST A
HILLARY CLINTON SYMPATHIZER.
I MEAN, I CANNOT BELIEVE THE
DOUBLE STANDARD OF OUR FRIENDS
IN THE MEDIA CHEW ON THE OTHER
FOOT.
THIS IS SOMEBODY THAT HATED
TRUMP, AND WE WERE GOING AFTER A
CLINTON PERSON LIKE THIS, IT
WOULD BE FRONT PAGE NEWS ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
>> Sean: I GOT TO GO.
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
WHERE IT GOES.
>> Sean: HOW IMPORTANT IS
MISSISSIPPI QUESTION RECOMMEND I
GOT TO ROLL.
>> IF YOU CARE ABOUT JUDGES,
EACH CARE ABOUT TAX CUTS, YOU
CARE ABOUT A STRONG, VOTE FOR